bitte geben sie ihre rechte hand und
sprechen sie mir nach ich kann meiner
seele harris schwöre feierlich dass sich
die verfassung der vereinigten staaten
unterstützen und verteidigen werde
gegen alle feinde ausländische und
inländische dass ich ihr treu und loyal
ergeben sein werde dass ich diese
verpflichtung aus freien stücken
eingehen ohne geistigen vorbehalt oder
die art die sicht sich ihr zu entziehen
und da sich die pflichten des amtes dass
ich übernehme gut untreue erfüllen werde
so wahr mir gott helfe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
adlung dem regal gerade gesehen haben es
ist jetzt ganz offiziell die
vize-präsidentin zu wenig gehört und vor
allem wo es gerade aufgezählt die erste
die ist die erste frau die erste
afroamerikanerin die erste asiatin also
käme der harris ist wirklich
bahnbrechend für so viele menschen und
jetzt hier mit euch beiden kann ich es
wahrscheinlich am meisten aussagen als
frau ist es großartig zu sehen dass sie
jetzt heute ins weiße haus einzieht
natürlich wir haben doch gerade gehört
ist das nicht alles aber ein wichtiger
schritt für alle frauen auf der ganzen
welt angesichts sagen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei beschaulich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren